you
hello and welcome to the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences with me to discuss
the 2007 Nobel Prize for chemistry is
going to karlstrom professor kallstrom
thank you very much for joining us so
soon after announcements being made
could we begin by telling the viewer
who's actually been awarded the 2007
nobel prize in chemistry it's a german
professor gal advil from Max Planck
Institute in the lane and he has got a
prize for his fundamental studies of
chemical processes occurring on surfaces
and could you explain for the non
chemists what what surface chemistry
actually is well it I mean normally
chemistry occurs either in the gas phase
or in the solution but in this case the
chemistry occurs at the interface
between a solid phase a metal face and a
gas phase and it's something in between
the solid the liquid phase chemistry and
the gas phase chemistry at some aspects
of both and it's very easy from the
point of view that compared to the solid
phase liquid phase chemistry because
it's not so complex but it's more
complex than the guests I saw it coming
from a complexity of the liquid phase to
the relative simpleness in the gas phase
this is something intermediate and we
can understand things there and we can
make predictions of what's going on in
the liquid phase safe to say so this is
a fundamental sort of area of physical
chemistry but it's one that has a wide
range of applications could you tell us
a few examples please yeah I mean long
before professor Arthur got his Nobel
Prize we actually utilized it for
example in the production of ammonia and
ammonia is the main ingredient as a
fertilizer and I mean in the beginning
of the last century we started our to
completely processes one was an obedient
process and one was a dreamer process at
the Harbor Bosch process and that is
refined by trial and error so it's
probably not possible to improve it very
much today by the findings of Professor
Ethel but he has laid the foundations
they to say
landscape is showing what what's
actually going wrong we're not knowing
what was going on before but now we
knows what's going on either in this
type of systems so we can understand
process like how how rust forms an iron
and how catalysts work and leaving the
ozone layer that works function exactly
all these kind of very important
chemical process we can understand today
and maybe tomorrow we can control them
and to say stop the rust to better than
we do today and we can make maybe even
better catalytic cleaning or exhaust
from the cars and say well and I mean
very many processes in chemistry
actually occurs at surface especially in
the heavy chemical industry Suffolk acid
is produced that way and many other
processes so it's very important
actually so what's professor rattles
contribution means the field of surface
chemistry what he has done is that he I
said to say thoroughly investigated some
of these fundamental processes and
clarified in detail how the atoms are
moving what was actually happening and
clarify the energetic landscape out
how's it to say how much energy is
required for coming from this step to
the next step and say what so we know
now in detail exactly what is happening
and that is to say a foundation for
making improvements I mean when you know
what things look like then it's much
easier to improve them then if you has
been done before us do it by trial and
error so he's really helped shape the
field here shaped the failures and I
mean it's a field which is today very
dependent on his work so is the price
being rewarded awarded for a single
discovery or a series discoveries that
rentals made its rewarded for a
mythology that he has developed to study
very complicated processes so it is for
one thing but it's a very complicated
thing so it's not one publication but
it's a series of publications which
altogether forms you to say the solution
to a very complicated problem it's one
or one complicated problem which
you it's a complicated it cannot be
solved in one step you have to give many
many steps in order to reach the final
solution and atlas basically taken all
of these steps by himself and could you
briefly say what the what the complex
problem is the complex problem is how
does a chemical reaction occur on a
chemical surface and there are not one
answer to the question I mean that's one
answer to the question with respect to
the production of ammonia there's
another answer to the question how is
carbon monoxide converted in carbon
dioxide in the exhaust of a car so so
has actually showed that are many
complex processes that are occurring in
these systems and in order to master it
we must see I understand the whole
picture and so what if professor rattles
discoveries allowed researchers to be
able to do well they have allowed us to
be able to do today to start to work
with these processes on a fundamental
level and to improve and systematically
I mean it has laid the landscape history
I mean has drawn the map for us now we
have to navigate in the map so this is
this is serious discoveries as you said
so why the the Nobel Committee decided
to walk professor at all this prize this
year all you mean by he didn't get it
the year before or the next year these
kind of questions we do not answer in
principle so there's no answer to that
question fortunately but but but also
you've given even audits one person only
now of course you could have ward it two
or three people is there anything to say
about whether whether you discussed
having other people involved being world
with the prize we do not discuss that
kind of questions either but we can say
that a professor at least outstanding in
the field and a final question what was
the professor littles reactions in the
news and he was very happy I was really
happy i would say and i believe it is
birthday today as well yes so it's a
great birthday present for i think he
thought he said that it was the best
birthday present but a man can get
unfortunately not all of us can get it
we hope one day we can thank you very
much professor cars from that's all from
us here now you can find out more about
the chemistry prize please visit
nobelprize.org the official website for
nobel foundation but for now from
stockholm goodbye
you